hello everyone for those of you who are
here this morning welcome back for those
of you who are new to the session this
afternoon welcome to the 2016 Roosevelt
Reading Festival we're so glad to have
you here today I think you already know
the format we'll talk for about a half
an hour then about ten minutes of a
question and answer and then we'll go
back and he'll set up and you'll be able
to get signed copies of the book which
are pretty wonderful the we're very
excited about this year here at the
library this is going to be our 75th
anniversary and at the end of June and
we're celebrating in many ways and this
Reading Festival is one of the things
that we think Franklin Delano Roosevelt
would both be really happy about because
this is exactly how they wanted this
site to be used as a center for people
to talk about the presidency about the
Roosevelt era and to bring people
together to have a meaningful
conversation to support programs like
this you probably saw up there we have
our membership table if you'd like to
become a member we would strongly
encourage that we greatly appreciate it
now the challenge we face here with
someone like David is that he is highly
accomplished I could spend the next half
an hour talking about his background but
I'm sure you'd rather hear him speak now
he served during both the Clinton and
the George W Bush administration as an
intelligence officer and a daily
intelligence briefing which is of course
why he got the idea for the book he was
a desk officer at the State Department
as well he currently consults and trains
and offers advice to government agencies
and corporations his received his PhD in
political science from Duke University
those of you who are basketball fans
well we can talk about that later he's
published a wide range of articles
security studies Houston Chronicle
skeptic magazine he appears in national
media regularly especially on the Fox
News Channel Fox and Friends this book
is really a fascinating book and it goes
right to one of these key transitional
moments in the presidency from Roosevelt
to today which is this daily
intelligence briefing his book is called
the book the president's book of secrets
you gotta love that
book of secrets the untold story of and
briefings of America's presidents from
Kennedy to Obama and of course during
the Roosevelt era there was no daily
intelligence briefing that sort of
evolved as the Cold War came what they
did have was the map room and if you go
to the museum you'll see sort of a minor
replica but we don't have a lot of great
photographs of it but Roosevelt wanted a
map room because Churchill had one and
so he wanted one and of course Churchill
also had a great Intelligence Agency
which the United States did not
Roosevelt one on one of them as well but
I think David was going to talk about
some of that
so enough for me I'd like you to welcome
David Reese and I hope you have a great
session thank you Paul and thank you to
everyone here at the Roosevelt Library
involved with the Reading Festival as a
heck of an event and thank you all for
coming and learning a bit about our
shared history here I am here to talk
about the the president's book of
secrets a colloquial term for the daily
intelligence that the President of the
United States has received for decades
in various forms the presidency in the
modern era is so different than what it
was 200 years ago but there was a few
key inflection points along the way I'm
gonna talk to you about some of those
inflection points focusing on both
President Roosevelt what came before him
what came after him but it does center
around what we take for granted today
which is that the President of the
United States receives top-secret
intelligence delivered to him personally
tailored to him personally to allow him
to anticipate threats to national
security and hopefully to identify
foreign policy opportunities and act
ahead of them
the president's Daily Brief or PDB is
that daily document now of top secret
intelligence including reporting and
assessments from classified and
unclassified sources alike
the CIA spies the National Security
Agency's listening posts the nation's
reconnaissance satellites all gather
information for it and then experts take
that information and paint a picture
about what's going on in a certain
international environment based on that
limited information and their own
and expertise of the foreign culture of
the foreign leaders that they're
studying for this book I did have the
chance to get direct input from all of
the living ex Presidents and vice
presidents from most of the living CIA
directors national security advisors
White House chiefs of staff secretaries
of state and defense so this story
really is their story I found in doing
the research that what we take for
granted today about the president
getting this kind of intelligence simply
wasn't true a long time ago I'm gonna
walk you through a little bit of that
because it relates a lot to the man
we're talking about most here today
Franklin Roosevelt and how he planted
the seeds for what we know today is the
modern delivery of intelligence to the
President of the United States first
I'll walk back a little bit to give you
a sense of what FDR faced when he was
coming into office relating to this
top-secret intelligence then I'll talk
about what happened during his
administration and then walk you briefly
through what his successors did with the
foundation that he laid before I take
your questions let's go back to George
Washington George Washington came into
office as president
there was no intelligence community but
he was no stranger to intelligence he
had been essentially his own spy master
as commander in chief of the Continental
Army but once in office he didn't have
anyone assessing International
development's for him and his successors
didn't either they face the same hurdles
seems strange to think about today but
if you think about the five successors
to George Washington the people who led
the nation for the 40 years after his
death they had extensive international
experience for that time all five of
them had been ambassadors in some cases
to more than one country or Secretary of
State more often than not both of those
things and occasionally acting Secretary
of War governor of Virginia or author of
Declaration of Independence there's a
lot of expertise there and yet they
didn't have anybody to help them
interpret what was going on around the
world they had to do that all themselves
over the next several decades going
forward over a hundred years in fact
that didn't change during the Civil War
Lincoln did walk across to go to get
some Telegraph's during the
spanish-american war McKinley did have a
small war room set up in the White House
President Wilson during the First World
War did get some intelligence
assessments they were from the British
he was getting them from the British in
Washington not from a United States
intelligence service which did not exist
as such so an FDR into his office that's
what he's facing but he had a dual
challenge that he faced he had Nazi
aggression in Europe and he had the rise
of the Japanese Empire across the
Pacific he needed more information and
more assessment of that information than
he was getting through other means so he
started creating the very institutions
that were lacking he tapped Wild Bill
Donovan to become the head of what
became the OSS originally the office of
the coordinator of information a great
Washington bureaucratic title if ever
there was one the coordinator of
information becoming the director of the
Office of Strategic Services most
stories about the Office of Strategic
Services or OSS focus on the cool stuff
they did they focus on the collection of
human intelligence they focus on the
propaganda efforts around the world they
focus on the sabotage that OSS
operatives did and aided throughout
World War two but there was another
unprecedented effort in world war two
with the OSS and that was an office
called the office of research and
analysis or as it became known R&A RNA
was the analytic effort RNA was the
group that Donovan called
his professors and these were the people
that the OSS recruited from some of the
nation's top universities Harvard Yale
Princeton other top universities to come
in and start assessing what was going on
around the world
to serve the president and top military
leaders they ended up at the peak of OSS
they ended up pulling in almost a
thousand political scientists economists
historians cartographers geographers and
others to write thousands of memos hand
books and other information
for the political and military leaders
of the time their job was to collate
information from various sources and at
the time the kind of sources they had
included diplomatic cables from the
State Department overseas they had
international media available to them
they'll said military reporting
available to them but there was one
thing they did not have they did not
have direct access to intercepted
foreign communications the kind of stuff
that the National Security Agency
collects now it was there but they
didn't have access to it so the
information they were providing to the
president used many means but not all
means that the United States had at the
time the leaders of the research and
analysis division in OSS really
struggled with how to make this relevant
to the president they had no trouble
getting this information to military
leaders in the field who needed it there
were some very good tactical
intelligence reports being produced but
they didn't have a good sense of what
Roosevelt needed and they didn't get a
lot of feedback this was essentially a
one-way street reports were being sent
up but not a lot of feedback was coming
back hard to tailor the product to the
person who needs it the most in that
kind of environment what the RNA leaders
did is they tried to make these
academically interesting reports that
all these professors were producing and
turn it into something that could be
actionable intelligence but they did
struggle with that Donavan innovated
something to try to get around this he
would send some of these RNA reports to
the president through the president's
secretary and he started putting cover
memos on top of them and the cover memos
at first were administrative descriptive
but over time Donovan's personality
started to shine through and these memos
started including some of the juiciest
tidbits of the spy reports that were
included in the reading stack underneath
them they started including some of
Donovan's own language putting a spin on
the dense academic prose appearing
within the reports Donovan's language
certainly embraced decidedly non
academic phrases he was giving Roosevelt
things like that old Fox
and this one's a mouthful contortions of
a putrified Nazi diplomacy seein CIA in
retrospective published several years
ago called the RNA effort topped by
these colorful memos from Donovan one of
the few original contributions to the
craft of intelligence by the United
States throughout its history this was
unique to develop intelligence analysis
of this sort for the president but as I
mentioned it was a one-way street FDR
was not giving a lot of feedback
certainly to the analysts writing these
reports not even to the senior
leadership of OSS about what kind of
interpretations and assessments he
needed to help him prosecute the war
effort so they ended up providing much
more background information than
insights personally directed for the
president in fact near the end of the
war in 1945 OSS through its RNA branch
produced a civil affairs handbook on
Germany that reached a whopping 2,000
pages Franklin Roosevelt liked to read
nobody likes to read that much
and yet the foundation for the modern
intelligence system was laid for the
first time there was an intelligence
service in the United States which had
as one of its objectives serving the
President of the United States Harry
Truman picked up on that very soon OSS
was disbanded fairly quickly after the
war but in early 1946 it was back it had
a new name there was a new head it was
called the director of Central
Intelligence and he headed what was
called the Central Intelligence Group
which eventually became the Central
Intelligence Agency Harry Truman started
getting what he called the daily summary
and this was a document that analysts at
CIA pulled together based on classified
information but this one was more
directed at Truman himself that is they
thought about what does Truman need and
what does he not need so he picked up on
what Roosevelt had built and got
something a little bit more focused on
him but even then they weren't getting
tons of feedback and over time they
didn't get the kind of response they
were looking for under the next
President Dwight Eisenhower it changed
even more because Dwight Eisenhower's
was used to a stately procession of
briefings
he used the National Security Council
system very well with topics planned out
weeks sometimes months in advance he was
not getting a daily intelligence
briefing personalized to him he received
some documents produced by the current
intelligence office and what was now the
CIA but there was not that close
relationship to the intelligence he was
receiving that would only happen under
John F Kennedy who had a very different
personality than Eisenhower in a very
different way of absorbing information
he liked to talk to people he liked
ad-hoc meetings with his advisers about
various issues that came up he could not
sit there still for hours for the long
meetings that Eisenhower was used to so
one day his military aide who had the
challenge of trying to provide him all
of these documents from the Pentagon
from the CIA from the State Department
and get it to what the president needed
he called in two CIA analysts and he
said look what I need is your help I
need you to help me come up with
something that I can give the president
that will give him everything he needs
to know and nothing that he doesn't that
will
take this huge stack of reports and boil
it down to the essential elements and
I'd really like it if you could put it
into a format that he could fold and put
into his suit pocket because we can't
seem to keep his attention for more than
a few minutes and that way he can read
it he can put it away for a meeting and
then pull it out again between meetings
and get through it during the day one of
the CIA officers looked at the other one
and smiled because he had been talking
about just such a product anticipating
Kennedy's personality and the change
here he had something in mind so much so
that within 24 hours they had a dry run
of the new product in something unheard
of in bureaucracies sense less than 24
hours they had a new product designed
for the President of the United States
in the hands of the military aide saying
what do you think he liked it he liked
it so much that the very next day he
took the inaugural copy of what became
known as the president's intelligence
checklist to John F Kennedy down at the
least Kennedy estate of Glenora near
Middleburg Virginia Kennedy was sitting
on his swimming pool diving board
between laps he pulled it out looked at
it seemed to like the short document
true to form put it down so he could
keep swimming before reading the rest of
it he was hooked it worked and for the
rest of his short presidency of John F
Kennedy seemed to appreciate the
president's intelligence checklist
reading it reacting to it
tasking some of his leading officers to
do things based on the items in it
he let into the circle of presidential
intelligence the Secretary of State and
the Secretary of Defense one person he
did not let into the inner circle was
Vice President Lyndon Johnson no love
lost between the two but that was quite
a surprise after that day in Dallas when
Lyndon Johnson is suddenly President of
the United States and the director of
central intelligence briefs him the next
day and shows him the president's
intelligence checklist giving no
indication that this is a new product
designed for him Lyndon Johnson was not
a stupid man he figured out he was
excluded perhaps that's why he never
took to this document this leads to the
birth of the document that we know today
because it has continued now for more
than 50 years in December 1964 CIA
figuring out that this wasn't working
for Johnson
they retitled it they reformatted it and
they gave his advisor something that
Lyndon Johnson could truly call his own
the president's Daily Brief
at this time and through most of its
history the president's Daily Brief has
been all three of those things it has
been the president's that is it's aimed
directly at the president it was aimed
at the personality of John F Kennedy
when it was known as the president's
intelligence checklist but they
continued it with Lyndon Johnson
delivering it to him at nighttime
because he liked to do his reading in
bed late at night it's the president's
Daily Brief
its daily it's been produced every
working day for more than 50 years it's
also brief some cases in history you can
find one-page examples of the
president's Daily Brief just a few short
summaries other cases it could stretch
to dozens of pages but usually somewhere
in between focus on what the president
needed to know Richard Nixon also
received the president's Daily Brief
every day to this day and with all the
research I did including talking to dr.
Henry Kissinger as National Security
Advisor
we can't be sure that he actually read
it Nixon did not love the CIA he felt
that he was pretty smart on foreign
policy and international affairs already
most sources indicate that he did read
it and at least he would have read it to
be aware of what the intelligence
community was saying but he did not have
a rich dialogue with its producers but
even there it was tailored to the
President of the United States they
changed its format to look more like a
legal brief thinking Nixon is a lawyer
he'll appreciate it in that format he
ended up having a shortened presidency
but before the end there was a new Vice
President Gerald Ford Gerald Ford came
into office he'd had some limited
experience with intelligence while he
was in the Congress but he came out to
the CIA headquarters to get a tour and
during that tour the Director of Central
Intelligence happened to walk him
through the office of current
intelligence that office that produced
the president's Daily Brief and other
high-level intelligence analysis sitting
there on the table happened to be a copy
of the president's Daily Brief
which he had not been seeing yet because
President Nixon and dr. Kissinger had
been limiting its distribution to them
vice president sees it says what's that
well that's the president's Daily Brief
this is what the president the National
Security Advisor get every day would you
like to see it why yes I would and thus
was born the first close briefing
relationship with a president because
what happened is they offered not only
the president's Daily Brief to Gerald
Ford his vice president they offered him
a personal briefer who everyday would
bring the product not to drop off and
pick up later but to sit with Gerald
Ford and talk through its content to
brief him on it to answer questions on
the spot to talk about some of the stuff
that was left on the cutting-room floor
when it was printed some of the richness
behind the analysis Ford loved it he
hosted the briefer at his kitchen table
at his house in Alexandria or in the car
ride downtown not too long from then
Richard Nixon resigned Gerald Ford
becomes president the real estate for
the briefer changed a little bit from a
kitchen table and Alexandria to the Oval
Office in the White House Gerald Ford
was the first president to receive not
only the president's Daily Brief but a
president's Daily Brief CIA working
level analytic briefer while in office
and he continued this for his first year
in office before he decided he
understood this well enough that he
could just read the book Jimmy Carter
came after him also did not take a
briefer but the format changed for him
as well another case of tailoring the
book to the President Jimmy Carter from
his time back as governor loved to write
on any document any memo he received he
would write instructions sometimes
things for him to remember but usually
instructions to his staff very clearly
written this is what I want done he
wanted the PDB in the same format and
he wrote all over those things to the
CIA brought the margins in created a lot
of whitespace a lot of room for Carter
to write in the president's Daily Brief
itself his successor Ronald Reagan has a
reputation the conventional wisdom is
that he didn't read much at all
certainly not top-secret intelligence
reports the truth is a little more
nuanced than that in fact we have
several reasons to believe that Ronald
Reagan did take his president's Daily
Brief very seriously first of all
everyone who worked closely with him has
attested to that fact if they put
something in front of him to read he
read it in fact the problem was they had
to limit what they gave to him because
if they put it in front of him he
thought he had to read it they would
sometimes highlight certain parts of a
report saying just read these it would
come back and he had read all of it a
second way we know is because of what he
wrote about it if you go through Ronald
Reagan's Diaries in their full length
which I have you will find plenty of
references to daily intelligence
sometimes he even writes in his diary
referring to the president's Daily Brief
or the PDB and reacting to things he saw
within it a third way you can tell well
we can't tell but a CIA historian who
can go into the vaults where the old
pdbs are kept still classified not
released but a CIA historian did that
and he was able to publish the results
of what he found he went through the
first 1000 or so copies of the PDB
during Reagan's administration and he
found in Reagan's hand markings not on
all of them but on a significant number
of them things like underlines brackets
put around things question marks when he
wasn't sure about something in one case
even writing on a page but that's not
what you said before and he circled on
the previous page how there was a
difference between something being said
on the same topic these are not the
signs of somebody who is not reading the
document it does appear he took it
seriously but something happened in his
administration that did have a major
effect and that is the PDB was getting
passed around a little bit especially
within the White House traditionally the
PDB has been limited to just a handful
of people the president and whomever the
president designates to receive it
during Reagan's era it started getting
photocopied at the White House the White
House chief of staff national security
adviser
had other people looking at it it was
often passed through the White House
Situation Room and people would look at
it there in fact there's the story that
one of the senior officials at the White
House was making a copy of the PDB
taking at home and storing it in his
garage at home you have to remember this
is top-secret intelligence with sources
and methods information in it very
sensitive information that was
discovered in the National Security
Adviser got those copies back and
destroyed them one person at the White
House was particularly upset by all this
and this was Vice President George HW
Bush he was the first man to be vice
president who had been the director of
the CIA he knew what it took to get the
information that got into this very
sensitive book he told me he was very
upset when he'd found out about this
maybe that's why when he became
president he instituted a practice for
the PDB that guaranteed the security of
the book he insisted that he get a copy
of the book from the CIA briefer and
sure enough like Gerald Ford had done
for one year
Bush 41 did it for four years he had a
CIA briefer in the room with him in the
Oval Office briefing him whenever he was
in Washington along with several
advisors and then when they were done
talking about the PDB the briefer took
the PDB with him and left and Bush told
the other recipients of the PDB the
Secretary of State Secretary of Defense
and others you're gonna do the same
thing you can read the book if you want
you don't have to have the briefer
briefed you but you're gonna read it in
the presence of the briefer and the
briefer is gonna take it away from you
when you're done guaranteeing the
sanctity of this product and allowing
the most sensitive information to get
inside of it the book changed a little
bit under President Clinton President
Clinton had an ebb and flow relationship
with the PDB he started out getting some
briefings but his personality was a
little bit different he liked to have
long tangential meetings about things
where discussions would go on forever
and it was very hard to schedule a set
time for a PDB briefing so over time
briefers would wait and wait the meeting
would never happen or would get
shortened sometimes they ended up just
dropping it off for him but he still
read it and took it very seriously he
told me it was something that he used to
help him make decisions almost every day
there was something in there he said
that he found useful in fact he even
tells the story which I detail in the
book about how it helped avoid nuclear
Armageddon when India and Pakistan were
going to war with each other and
something he read in the PDB helped him
defuse that situation following that was
george w bush george w bush did what his
father had done take a briefing every
day with an intelligence brief
but he took the briefing process up two
notches one he decided from the
beginning he was gonna have a briefer
not only briefed him when he was in
washington but wherever he was in the
world and he had his CIA PDB briefer
travel with him on domestic and foreign
trips number two he also decided to
supplement the PDB briefing process in
his second term he added what were
called deep dives where in addition to
getting this daily document of
everything you needed to know he brought
in analysts the world-class experts
primarily from CIA and then from other
intelligence agencies as well to talk
with him in depth about the crises of
the day in the first 18 months after
they did this he had a had over two
hundred analysts come in to talk with
him in some cases for up to an hour in
depth about one particular country or
one particular issue that brings us to
our current President Barack Obama I
told you the PDB has been personalized
for every president that was made
obvious Monday when the White House
publicized a photo of the president
reading his president's Daily Brief on
an iPad the president's Daily Brief has
now electrons on a screen not ink on
paper still assessments of world affairs
but now presented in a way that can
allow multimedia graphics can allow
videos to be played things like that
it's easy to see this as a modern
invention because it's now on an iPad
but it's the same intelligence
assessments that started really with
Franklin Roosevelt back in World War two
when he was getting information from the
first analytic service that the United
States government created the office of
research and analysis I'd be interested
to hear what you think about this topic
you interested in answering any
questions you have thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
please come up to the microphone if you
have any questions that we can record it
for c-span and I'll start with a
question for you like oh when the
material goes back to the CIA what
happens to it and at what point is it
ever Declassified yeah let me start with
the backend of that we do have something
revolutionary in the history of the
president's Daily Brief that is
happening right now
traditionally the president's Daily
Brief has been off-limits to
declassification efforts
apart from a very few for select
historical reasons like what was told to
the president right before he was
assassinated in the 1960s what was told
Dylan in Johnson right after the
assassination other than that
P D B's traditionally have been kept
walled off from investigation and from
research that changed last year the
decision was made that nothing stays
classified forever and going back 40
years they have started declassifying
the president's Daily Brief and before
that the president's intelligence
checklist last fall the Kennedy era and
Johnson era daily intelligence documents
were Declassified with some redactions
some things still classified because
some of those people that are being
referred to are still around today and
they probably don't want to have that
information out or some of the sources
and methods of intelligence collection
and analysis are still being used today
and it would jeopardize national
security but it's amazing going through
them and they're available on the
website of I believe both the Central
Intelligence Agency and perhaps the
Kennedy and Johnson libraries at least
have links to them you can see what John
Kennedy was reading every day and what's
most surprising about that is the
colloquial language that was used back
then now it's a little more bureaucratic
it's a little more intense in terms of
the level of the assessment back then
there were pieces in the president's
daily book of secrets like President
Nasser of Egypt is considering a reform
program we doubt it will amount to much
that was the whole piece that was it
a lot simpler than the kind of things we
see now the Nixon and Ford era
president's Daily Brief s-- are going to
be coming out later this year and
Declassified historians are gonna love
this because they're gonna get to see
what did Nixon at least theoretically
and Kissinger certainly see every day
regarding Vietnam regarding the 1973 war
things like that so that is a process
that's going on now the rest of the pdbs
are kept locked up some of them are
considered presidential records because
the president made markings on them and
those are kept secure CIA in its vaults
has all the copies of the PDB ever
produced with time we'll get to see most
or all of them thank you please I guess
my question is have politics taken a
backseat to these briefings can you
explain what you mean by that
well I have different political leanings
in these briefings right thank you
the objective of the intelligence
analysis service is objectivity it is
the Prime ethos of the intelligence
business calling it like you see it
telling it like it is from your
perspective the primary sin of an
intelligence analyst is skewing the
analysis based on your feelings about
the policy or based on your feelings
about the person reading the
intelligence assessment at its best
the president's Daily Brief and all
other intelligence analysis is timely
that is it's delivered at a time that
somebody can do something about the
information within it its objective it
is not slanted or biased and hopefully
it's accurate you can't always hit all
three but the goal is to hit all three I
have not found in my research any cases
of the information in the president's
intelligence reports being deliberately
slanted there have always been
perceptions of such because imagine it
you're the president of the United
States you've made a very difficult
decision about a foreign policy and
trust me no decision gets to the
President's desk if it's easy it is a
tough decision if it gets there you
finally make a decision you've invested
the US government and perhaps your
political career in that decision and
then you're getting intelligence
assessments telling you that the
situation overseas is a disaster it's
very easy for you to read that and say
why do they hate me politically why are
they telling me this don't they see
aren't they Americans too it's easy to
understand that but the presidents who
got it the worst and I'm thinking here
of cases like Lyndon Johnson and Vietnam
we're getting things about Vietnam they
did not want to see things like george w
bush on iraq they did not stop getting
president's daily intelligence reports
they kept reading it in george w bush's
case that's when he decided to get more
intelligence reports when they were
telling him things that were not in line
with what he wanted his policy to be
doing he invited them in more often to
tell him more bad news that's probably a
good thing ensuring that the
intelligence train keeps on running
thank you can you hear me
yeah when Winston Churchill and
Bletchley Park broke the Enigma code
given how close Churchill was to
Roosevelt did he let him know they had
done it and did they forward
intelligence during World War two that
was helpful to the United States or not
I don't know because I did not
investigate the British relationship
with the u.s. I do know that the
intelligence analysts did not have
access to even United States
SIGINT or signals intercepts that's the
communication of foreign intercepts that
would develop during the Truman
administration that they let the
intelligence analysts writing for the
president into the fold of this
information that has continued from this
day forward the relationship with the
British overall however does have a role
with the PDB because the president's
Daily Brief does include information
from any source available to
intelligence analysts and if that means
that the British government passing
through normal channels gives
information there's no reason that
couldn't appear in a report for the
president but I don't know about the
specific meetings between the two
just does the Republican and Democratic
nominees receive the same presidential
Daily Brief and how long does that
practice about going on right this goes
back quite a ways the the backstory to
the candidates briefings really begins
with Harry Truman so you have to
remember Harry Truman becomes president
he doesn't even know about the Manhattan
Project and he did not want people
coming into the presidency like he did
unaware of something very important
so in 1952 he offered to both candidates
the president's Daily Brief let me
correct that it wasn't the president's
Daily Brief at that point it was just an
intelligence briefing and it did cover
top-secret information it was not the
same as the president's Daily Brief
which didn't even exist yet but that
tradition has carried forward all
presidential candidates since that time
are offered a top secret intelligence
briefing after their nomination one
historical quirk to that in 1980 Jimmy
Carter it was obvious he was going to be
the nominee but he was not yet the
nominee he got a message through to
President Ford can I get an intelligence
briefing and President Ford agreed to do
it and he gave instructions to the
Director of Central Intelligence to go
and talk to President Carter but the
purpose of it was to talk about the
logistics for the intelligence briefings
that would follow the nomination the
Director of Central Intelligence at the
time George HW Bush exceeded his mandate
and they ended up having a full
intelligence discussion even before he
was technically the nominee but that is
the historical aberration most nominees
have chosen to receive this briefing one
who did not was in 1984 former Vice
President Walter Mondale was running
against Ronald Reagan he was offered a
briefing declined to take it his
reasoning which he said several years
later his reasoning was he was already
obvious I was going to lose the election
so what was the point
one key distinction however after the
nomination candidates are offered in
intelligence briefing this is a a tour
of the international environment this is
what's going on in various countries
this is what we think is happening it is
not an introduction to covert action it
is not an introduction to intelligence
operations it does not include very
sensitive information that is saved for
after there is a president-elect at that
point traditionally the sitting
president has authorized the
president-elect to start receiving the
same daily intelligence report the PDB
that he receives historically this has
gone pretty well over the years one
major exception the year 2000 there was
an election and we didn't know who won
there was no problem on the Democratic
side the candidate for the presidency Al
Gore was the vice president he had been
receiving the president's Daily Brief
every day for the last eight years but
you also had governor Bush in Austin and
as the time kept going by people started
to get nervous they felt it wasn't right
to give him this most sensitive
intelligence product if he wasn't going
to be the president on the other hand
they didn't want the president to come
into office with only a few weeks of
seeing this intelligence and not being
prepared to use it once in office so a
rare historical decision was made the
Clinton administration decided to give
George W Bush the PDB before the Florida
recount had been resolved so that he
would be prepared
it was one of the major players in that
drama it turned out was a Soviet agent
President Truman found out about this of
course he was shocked to learn that
FDR's Treasury and his State Department
had been riddled with Soviet agents
after he learned about this did anything
change fundamentally in the the way the
president was briefed on intelligence
man right when it comes to the
president's briefings thank you and the
the briefings of those whom the
president has designated to also receive
the PDB and the briefings it is such a
small group that even in a horrible case
like that it was only the Secretary of
State and the Secretary of Defense
usually occasionally a deputy would also
get it who had received the president's
Daily Brief so changing that document
because of espionage or other issues no
evidence of that happening I could find
no evidence of the president's Daily
Brief being violated in any way now
there is a chance of that though because
if you want the president's Daily Brief
to be useful if you're the President of
the United States you could decide I'm
the only person getting it and you can
put anything in there you want because
I'm the top of the system but then who
are you gonna talk to about it really
useful for you but as president you're
not actually implementing foreign policy
you need a lot of people to do that so
you have to have other people reading
this top-secret intelligence so that you
can debate it you can decide what are we
going to do on the other hand if you
disseminate your book of secrets to
hundreds of people the chances of
something like that that would be a
disaster now this has been an evident
flow throughout the history of the
president's Daily Brief some I mentioned
have restricted it to just one or two
people in this administration it's going
to dozens of people it also went to many
people during the Clinton administration
as well that's a decision each president
has to make based on his or her
leadership style and the crises of the
day since the CIA is sort of the
editor-in-chief and owner of the
briefing can you comment on whatever
coordination or lack of coordination
there might be with intelligence that
comes from
say FBI if its domestic etc right up
until about ten years ago you've nailed
it the CIA
owned the president's Daily Brief the
CIA produced it the CIA edited it the
CIA delivered it the CIA got the
feedback on it and then would rinse and
repeat and do the same thing every day
that was up until ten years ago in the
aftermath of 9/11 and the Iraq WMD
issues the Office of the Director of
National Intelligence was created the
PDB was handed to that new organization
and is under the control of the Director
of National Intelligence now CIA is
still heavily involved in it but the
book is now open to authors from any
intelligence agency it is coordinated
around the intelligence community giving
more people a chance to get input to the
president they're still editing in
bureaucracy involved but that is done at
the level of the Director of National
Intelligence and his senior officers I I
did ask george w bush in whose
administration this change happened I
said what did you see
when suddenly this thing that has been
going on for decades in this institution
is transferred to a new organization
what did you notice he said I didn't
notice any difference I mean most of it
was still being written by CIA and my
briefer was still the same briefer a CIA
officer there was nothing really that
different for me a whole lot of stuff
going on different behind the scenes but
it didn't really change for the
President of the United States who after
all is the first customer of the product
what we were talking earlier and I
mentioned I'd read Kate Anderson
brower's book and the residents right
and one thing I didn't mention earlier
when we were talking is that that she
said that all those maids and butlers
and everyone were that works in the
White House they're so trusted that if
the president leaves something important
on his Nightside table I don't know if
it'd be the presidential presidential
Daily Brief or not but but if they're if
the president's meeting with his closest
advisors in the Oval Office or the
Situation Room with the Cabinet Room and
they and he realizes he's left something
important on the nightstand sometimes
they'll have a butler bring it over that
um so you'll have a butler coming in
with a plate of chocolate chip cookies
and maybe some very sensitive document
right that would not surprise me because
the the handling of anything that
touches the president or his near the
president has that ritual in that
protocol around it it would surprise me
if many of the the butler's and other
help at the White House we're touching
the president's Daily Brief even in the
times when it was disseminated a little
more widely and passed around generally
it was kept within the national security
folder that every National Security
Advisor gives to the president now when
that's back in someone's office they may
be flipping through it and they're not
supposed to or in the Situation Room
they would have to assemble and
dissemble this folder every day back
when it was the paper product for the
president I don't think it would get
around much more widely than that now it
is important to remember though it is
the president's book if the president
decides that the president wants to take
it upstairs to the residence and leave
it on his nightstand all day that's
what's going to happen if the president
the United States decides that instead
of an iPad or instead of a printed
product that he or she wants to receive
the president's Daily Brief in the form
of interpretive dance
there's gonna be a lot of intelligence
officers learning how to dance it is a
product tailored to the current
president no matter what the personal
style thank you all free attention look
forward to seeing you outside
[Applause]